les gens les gens avec la séquence
décryptage ils ont bien aimé le film
mais vous les avez pris très tôt le
matin c'était une séance très très
matinale
la séquence décryptage avec tes invités
issables
bonsoir d'être merci d'être venu sur le
plateau musicien auteur compositeur
interprète et puis Luc Miserey bénévole
au sein de l'association d'aide au
développement de faradala association
créée à Trappes par la maman dit ça
justement je suppose
un mot déjà sur cette association qui
aide faradala Issa vous allez
m'expliquer
ces gens-là alors qui vous êtes et vous
avez demandé à les recevoir en plus
bien l'association d'aide alors donc
c'est une association qui s'est créée
assez récemment pour
aider le village de faradala mais
au-delà la volonté c'est dans un premier
temps d'avoir une démarche humanitaire
et puis aussi de déboucher derrière sur
une démarche de coopération donc il y a
deux projets en cours
qui porte sur l'amélioration de l'école
et qui porte sur la création d'un puits
et pour ces projets on a obtenu des
subventions du Conseil Général des
Yvelines on a on est en train de de
démarcher on espère obtenir des
subventions également du conseil
régional et sur l'école on a eu des
subventions d'une association qui
s'appelle Solidarité Laïque qui
travaille notamment avec la Ligue de
l'enseignement et également du Crédit
Mutuel sur la base d'un projet jeune qui
a été porté par une jeune trappiste
puisque on travaille tous pour révéler
des jeunes trappistes il y en a qui
réussissent dans la culture et ailleurs
mais il y en a aussi qui peuvent
s'intéresser qui œuvrent pour qu'on vive
mieux ensemble tous les jours et ça vous
pensez quoi d'initiative ça paraît pas
mal moi ça me parle puisque bon déjà
c'est ma mère voilà tout simplement et
deuxième chose
mais le projet c'est un projet que ma
mère a mis en place et du coup moi ça me
touche puisque déjà l'école c'est
important même si tout à l'heure je dis
j'ai dit que j'ai fait l'école
buissonnière depuis j'arrive même pas à
le dire tellement j'ai pas fait d'école
depuis depuis l'âge de 19 ans j'ai
arrêté mais je me dis que c'est
important il y a plein d'enfants qui ont
le droit à
à apprendre ils ont le droit d'apprendre
et de savoir lire d'écrire donc c'est
important et moi je le ressens bien
aujourd'hui par exemple quand je reçois
des textes pour apprendre un film et ben
il faut que j'apprenne bien mon texte il
faut que je sache lire un contrat il
faut que je sache tout ça parce que
aujourd'hui on se dit ouais on va
arriver à un stade où on est reconnu
mais il y a plein de choses derrière
qu'on n'attend pas mais savoir lire un
contrat c'est pas mal parce que on peut
se faire avoir donc allez à l'école pour
pour voir déjà vous défendre avec les
lois l'association a été fondée en 2009
c'est bien ça c'est cela en 2009 nous
étions présents lors d'une des premières
opérations pour récolter des fonds on
des redécouvre ce sujet diffusé sur
notre antenne le 2 novembre 2009
une chanteuse si c'est un compteur
Albert Joseph Titus quelques-uns des
artistes réunissent à Jean-Baptiste
Clément de Trappes profit de
l'association aide au développement de
faradala une association créée il y a
trois mois pour venir en aide à ce
village du Mali dans la région de Kita
cette première soirée caritative a
permis de dégager 463 euros de bénéfices
l'argent ça va servir de faire l'eau
potable d'abord c'est ça qu'on veut
après ça on verra pour les écoles il y a
beaucoup de problèmes au niveau du
village notamment des problèmes de
d'eau potable des problèmes de santé
problème de l'éducation dans le cadre de
l'école et puis il y a d'autres
problèmes dans les activités générales
de revenir bien évidemment avec les
femmes on envisage aussi de travailler
sur des échanges culturels
à savoir que c'est pas simplement nous
verre le Mali mais que c'est un échange
53 adultes et une quinzaine d'enfants
ont participé à cette première soirée
qui en appellera d'autres l'association
va rechercher d'autres financements
auprès de la ville de Trappes ou encore
du conseil général dans le cadre d'un
programme de coopération internationale
les résultats obtenus depuis 2009 depuis
ce reportage les choses ont avancé
bah elles avancent concrètement parce
qu'on espère bien commencer les travaux
avant la fin de cette année donc
alors on attend un peu la décision du
conseil régional parce que c'est
compliqué parce que chaque collectivité
territoriale assez propre critères donc
c'est compliqué le Conseil général nous
fait inversement sur trois ans donc en
trois fois
il veut qu'on commence des choses mais
pour verser la suite mais en même temps
on est obligé de chercher une diversité
de subventionnement parce qu'il ne
souhaite pas on peut tout à fait le
comprendre être les seuls financeurs
mais après on est dépendant des
conditions de des autres donc le conseil
régional faut qu'on attende sa décision
qui normalement devrait intervenir le 16
novembre
et à partir de là commencer les travaux
puisque
le conseil régional lui ne veut pas
qu'on commence avant qui qu'il attribue
donc c'est c'est parfois un peu
cornélien quoi et donc au travers de
tout ça quand même je veux
remercier les deux personnes chevilles
ouvrières qui ont beaucoup porté ces
dossiers qui sont Vanessa petit et
Mariam Doumbia c'est marrant ça c'est
qui c'est d'où vient la terre il y a
beaucoup de tombe bien sur ce plateau
avec nous à bout qui fait de la musique
parcours atypique on avait déjà parlé
sur cette antenne au début vous étiez
dans l'informatique changement de
carrière pour passer à l'artistique
j'aimerais monter le regard du frère sur
le changement de parcours comme ça pour
se tourner vers l'artistique changement
de parcours
réveillez-vous à 4h du matin avec un
frère qui vous dit tiens j'ai un nouveau
son écoute attends je vais te faire
écouter
on est fan de son grand frère depuis
qu'on est tout petit mon frère je le
regarde comme ça depuis toujours et bah
oui à 4h du matin je me réveillais et
j'étais comme ça devant son ordinateur
je comprenais derrière mais à 8h je
comprenais plus mais oui mon frère si
oui je l'ai fait venir sur le plateau
c'est parce que c'est c'est un booster
pour moi c'est c'est un exemple et et il
m'épate souvent dans dans ce qui peut
proposer en musique alors Abou le
changement de carrière c'était pourquoi
pour faire un petit peu tourner vers
l'artistique comme le petit frère du
coup
non pas du tout parce que en fait moi
j'avais déjà ça en moi depuis un moment
et à l'époque où j'ai changé j'estimais
que si je le faisais pas maintenant
parce que je voulais faire de ma vie ce
me serait peut-être passé à côté donc
non vraiment c'était peut-être aussi
pour donner l'exemple pour dire que
voilà il faut essayer d'aller vers ce
qu'on souhaite et même par rapport à
Issa c'est vrai qu'au début autant moi
que mes frères mes deux autres soeurs on
a essayé de le protéger par rapport à ça
parce que c'est vrai que quand il a
voulu arrêter pour la comédie etc ça a
été assez difficile au niveau de la
famille de le faire accepter en tout cas
au niveau des parents donc en tout cas
moi le but c'était vraiment d'essayer de
le protéger pour que lui il puisse
justement
par faire son talent en fait par rapport
à ça donc c'était vraiment ça l'idée et
il nous a pas du tout déçu à ce niveau
là et vraiment il a donné le maximum
pour arriver là où il est aujourd'hui
quoi donc
2006 2007 c'était la préparation du
premier clip tout à fait il était
présent reportage
les dossiers que les autres
une nouvelle étape de franchie pour
about son premier clip tout juste
finalisé et maintenant disponible sur
Internet et devrait prochainement être
diffusé sur les chaînes musicales on a
tourné ça dans l'école de musique et de
danse de Trappes ou moi j'ai l'habitude
de répéter et donc je me suis appelé à
faire ce montage donc tu m'as quand même
pris à peu près 3 à 4 semaines quoi là
ça a été des journées qui commençaient à
10h du matin pour finir la plupart du
temps à 4h du matin donc c'est vraiment
assez chargé effectivement à contrecœur
je quitte ma patrie comme nombreux
Africains je fuis la misère et s'écrit
vivant ou jour le jour je lutte sans
cesse pour éviter mon retour pourquoi
sommes-nous pris pour des proies
pourquoi suis-je un ennemi pour toi
pourquoi
devrais-je mourir de faim sans lutter
pour un meilleur destin
à 32 ans il est en passe de réussir son
pari se faire un nom dans la musique lui
qui était encore il y a quelques temps
ingénieur en informatique il a décidé de
changer de vie et on à peine une année à
fonder son propre label sorti son
premier City trop tôt produit et trouver
un distributeur depuis le 28 mai le
nouveau souffle de la Freebox est
disponible auprès des disquaires de la
France entière au début ça a une bonne
accroche au niveau du public j'ai des
bons retours au niveau des ventes
maintenant comme par rapport à ma
difficulté c'est que ça s'est passé en
fait donc 28 mai suite à son a eu la
période des vacances donc j'ai août ou
là bas ça a un petit peu baissé
difficile de mener seul une carrière
s'il continue à composer pour sortir un
nouvel album il doit faire beaucoup de
sacrifices et a choisi de donner moins
de concerts beaucoup d'énergie et de
fatigue au quotidien mais en tout cas
aucun regret autant faire les choses
comme on les aime à fond même si c'est
peu de temps que tirer un poids tout au
long de sa vie en disant j'aurais dû
j'aurais dû
ce sujet c'était donc en 2007 depuis les
choses ont bien avancées pour Abou une
toute dernière question être dans
l'artistique dans la famille plusieurs
membres de la famille ça aide pour se
soutenir quand c'est plus ou moins
difficile ou pas je pense que ça marche
aussi
que c'est pas c'est pas ça qui va nous
soutenir c'est la famille déjà qui qui
est en face de enfin qui est là pour
nous soutenir qu'on fasse plombier ou
chanteur ou comédien il y a toujours la
famille qui est là pour pour n'importe
quel souci et c'est le premier repère
merci hâte d'être venu à tous les deux
d'avoir répondu à l'invitation dit ça
nous poursuivons cette émission dernière
séquence après le rappel des titres par
le face à face
j'espère qu'on se retrouvera dans
l'actualité de ce mercredi 19 octobre le
laboratoire d'analyses médicales de
Magny-les-Hameaux pourrait fermer chaque
mois il reçoit 1200 personnes la mairie
se mobilise les inspecteurs du permis de
conduire sont en grève un mouvement
national et illimité nous verrons les
conséquences dans les Yvelines notamment
pour ces candidats qui ne pourront pas
passer leur permis cette semaine une
exposition consacrée aux addictologistes
se déroulent jusqu'au 29 octobre à
l'Hôtel de Ville de Guyancourt le fruit
du travail mené conjointement entre un
photographe un addictologue et de jeune
lycéens il s'appelle
Issa Doumbia à l'affiche depuis une
semaine de beurre sur la ville comme
bien d'autres avant lui Issa a fréquenté
des bancs de Déclic Théâtre attrapent
une école du talent qui a vu notamment
débuter Jamel Debbouze